this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by the following message
in a world where less is more to men or
on a journey dude what are you doing oh
no I was just trying the whole
advertising thing out single work but uh
I guess not you know advertisements suck
and so this episode and all of our
episodes are 100% advertisement free if
you do want to support the podcast you
can just go to the minimalists calm
slash donate we hope you enjoy the show
every little thing you think that's mean
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet you'll be
fine without it
hello everybody and welcome to the
minimalists podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less I'm Joshua fields Milburn and
I am Ryan Nicodemus and that makes us
the minimalists this is episode number
seven of the minimalist podcast and
today we are going to talk about stuff
stuff yes so uh Ryan what'd you do this
weekend
this weekend I went snowboarding me and
Mariah went down to her family's house
about an hour south of Missoula hit up a
mountain called lost trail and had an
awesome day snowboarding and then Sunday
we just did like the boring Sunday stuff
you know errands and grocery shopping
and cleaning and things like that what
about you man Sunday night just trying
to get Ella to bed and uh she was having
her own version of a packing party I
don't think she knows what packing party
is yet which she calls Ryan the other
jock by the way she honors me uh she
fight fights going to bed much like Ryan
does actually and one of her tactics
this weekend was to start grabbing all
of the stuff in her room and she just
kept
she had this incantation that she was
saying over and over all my stuff is
going bye-bye all my things are going
bye-bye all my things are going bye-bye
and I was that's also I was calling her
a minimalist thought well it was sort of
awesome because she was just taking all
of her books and like her dolls and
everything and chucking it into the huge
pile in the living room I got to tweet
about that experience I set up a count
for Ella if anyone wants to follow it
it's just at Ella sandwich there's a
whole whole story behind that
she says the darndest things as it were
and and so I get to I get to really
enjoy that and and so we were dealing
with her stuff this weekend and we
should probably go ahead and start this
episode with some voicemails who's our
first voicemail from Kaitlyn I'd love to
hear your recommendations for someone
who has a passion that involves using or
having a lot of stuff so I love cooking
and it brings a lot of value to my life
but I've also found I tend to accumulate
pots pans utensils appliances gadgets
because I'm trying to cook a lot of new
things I also love scrapbooking and
crafting and that involves a lot of
paper products scissors tools
knickknacks what do you do when the
experiences that add value to your life
also involve a lot of material item what
do you do if you're passionate about
something and it brings you a lot of
stuff like you've picked the wrong
passion sorry sorry you've lost you've
lost the game know that that's a really
good question I've had this approached
this question approached a couple
different ways I've had people ask me
what do I do if I'm an artist I've got
all these art supplies or like her what
do I do if I'm a scrapbooker or in my
case I'm a snowboarder so I've got a lot
of equipment there I guess I would start
by answering Kaitlyn's question by
saying that for me all of the things
that I have when it comes to
snowboarding for example I have exactly
what I need
meaning I don't have to snowboarding
jackets I don't have multiple snowboards
multiple bindings
I have exactly what I need I have one
pair of gloves one snowboarding jacket
that actually kind of doubles as another
jacket that I can wear around if I want
to so it's kind of multi-purpose but
yeah I would start there for sure is
asking do you have what you need already
with your passion yeah we don't we don't
want anyone to deprive themselves of the
stuff that they need to pursue what
they're passionate about or cultivate
their passion my partner Rebecca she is
a dietician and she's phenomenal cook
but I can tell you that she doesn't need
a ton of kitchen utensils in kitchen
things that often the accoutrements that
we surround ourselves with are an excuse
that sort of prevent us from doing the
thing we actually want to do which in
this case could be cooking or my former
spouse Carrie is definitely a
scrapbooker and and had the
accoutrements for that but it doesn't
require that you have every single tool
that has ever been made to pursue that
hobby to pursue that passion really the
question is what do you truly need and
and then do you truly need it going
forward because you may try out a tool
that helps augment your your hobby but
it may not continue to provide that same
amount of value and so you have to be
honest with yourself another tip that I
would have is is quite often you can
borrow or rent the things that you might
need and are you talking about before we
started recording with your snowboard
and this weekend yeah I don't think that
you have to necessarily buy the item
right away or you can consume a used
version of the item you can go onto
Craigslist you can go on to eBay or
wherever and and that way we're not
producing all of these brand new things
and using all the materials and
resources the the stuff is already out
there and so if you want to use it for a
temporary period of time you can get it
from Craigslist and if it doesn't work
out if it's not truly bringing you value
you can put it back on Craigslist and
get rid of it
yeah the snowboard that Josh is talking
about for the listeners I went in demo
a snowboard this Saturday cost me 25
bucks to try it out on the mountain I've
been looking at this snowboard for the
last three or four weeks really deciding
whether or not I wanted to purchase a
new snowboard the one I have is about
eight years old
Mariah she needed some new bindings her
board was getting pretty wrecked so I
was thinking maybe I could give her my
old one and get a new one
but I'll tell you when I saw that
snowboard for the first time I called
Mariah up and I was like I'm gonna get
this like I gotta get this and she was
like well why don't you think about it
for a little bit I'm like yeah I know I
will think about it for a little bit but
but I mean that was my first impulse was
to go ahead and buy it and I even
without Mariah's advice I still probably
would have waited but I certainly still
get those urges in the way that I can
bat those urges is putting things
putting those decisions on hold for a
couple weeks or maybe putting it on hold
for 30 days I could see that with
Caitlin how the kitchen stuff would be
so much more difficult though right
because like you're flipping through a
catalogue and it's like oh here's a
here's a I got a slicer right here
here's a Bill Clinton cookie cutter set
like oh my I like Bill Clinton I might
use that one day and then only costs
$2.99 I could see where it would be even
easier to buy impulsively when it comes
to that
so for Caitlin and anyone else out there
who has a hobby or a passion that
involves a lot of stuff I would work on
the impulse buying by not impulse buying
meaning if you go to the store and let's
say you're an artist and you go to the
store and you've got a list of art
supplies get what is only on that list
don't get anything else impulsively if
there's something else there that you
feel like you want then put it on a list
for the next time you go I do that a lot
at the grocery store I'm a best buy best
buy gets me a lot like I go in there I'm
like me literally shiny new gadgets and
I'll sit there and play with all the
demos and totally get that impulse to
upgrade or to purchase a new gadget but
but ultimately I have stopped the
impulse buying easier said than done
but it's like any other habits if you
incorporate it into your life if you
practice that the more I should say just
the more you practice
the easier it gets and you can remove
those temptations as well you know if if
you're really tempted by Best Buy don't
go to Best Buy don't go to Best Buy if
you really tend to buy the the cookware
catalog then don't look through the
cookware catalog recycle it get rid of
it and I think that's true with any
temptation the more temptation we put in
front of us the the more apt we are to
to succumb to that temptation so we we
definitely need to be we need to be
careful with with what we have what we
bring into our lives and and you know
question whether or not is this
something that I'm collecting you know
we often talk about how I think
collections can be dangerous I think
collecting is a dangerous word when
we're doing when we're collecting the
things just for the sake of collecting
and and so you know it it's really a
euphemism or semantics for hoarding in
many cases and so we hoard all these
things we're not actually using because
we're going to use them someday and some
non-existent hypothetical future like oh
if I do get that avocados slicer and
that that fruit dehydrator or whatever
and by the way there's nothing wrong
with either one of those things if
you're truly going to get value from it
but the question is are you going to
give value from it and is there a
responsible way to bring that into your
life you don't have to order brand new
from from the infomercial do we saw a
stat recently about 99 percent of things
that are that are purchased are no
longer used after the first six months
of purchase that means we continue to
use only 1% 1% of the things we purchase
after a six month period
and the way to combat that is there's
enough stuff out there already we can
consume many of the things it doesn't
have to be everything it's not all or
nothing it isn't to be draconian it can
be where we try to consume as
responsibly as possible and and if we're
consuming half of our things or 80% of
our things that are used you can bring
it into your life you can test it out
and then you can have a process in your
life to make sure you're letting go when
it isn't adding value yeah I'll tell you
another thing that I ask myself -
especially at Best Buy when I get that
urge
when I see whatever gadget maybe I'll
ask myself did I need that before I saw
it and the majority of the time when I
get those impulses I didn't necessarily
need it and it's same thing goes for the
stuff we hold on to we hoard it's like
you see something you're like oh I might
use that one day but were you even
thinking about that item before you saw
it sitting in your hoard
yeah and like I said Bex as a dietician
and she she's a phenomenal cook and she
was doing a little mini packing party on
her kitchen recently and she was going
through her stuff she was employing her
her version of what we call the 9090
rule basically have I used this in the
last 90 days and am I going to use it in
the next 90 days now that interval might
not be right for everyone it might be 30
days for some people it tends to be 30
days for me it may be 120 days for
someone else but usually the ninety nine
year old the reason I like that is it
works for clothes it works for gadget
works for whatever because it accounts
for seasonality right if you look back
90 days that's three months ago you look
you look forward 90 days that's three
months so covers a six month period
which is going to cover pretty much any
season and and so you can take into
account seasonality you can take an
account the the past and the future as
long as you're honest with yourself
about what you're consuming yeah what's
going to move on to a voicemail from
Matt I don't a question for you I have
been over the last couple of years I've
really started to embrace this idea of
decluttering and I have done a really
good job with that I think the one of
the things that kind of emerged out of
that was this idea of the everyday carry
I've gotten rid of so many things but I
found and I sort of had like a big core
set of items if you will that I carry
with me that I felt like I needed every
day and I just wonder if a you know
joxer around it's either one of you
happen to have some type of everyday
carry that you maybe have on your person
or to a bag or something that you carry
with you in a few maybe just be willing
to elaborate with us on the podcast
about what that
so Ryan do you have something that you
carry with you every day no way man I'm
a minimalist is walking around naked all
day now um I carry my wallet
I carry my phone and then I've got my
computer bag that I necessarily don't
carry every day but certainly if I'm
using my computer and going out
somewhere I'll use that computer bag um
I'll tie it in my computer bag I always
have like some screen wipes to clean off
my computer screen they're really handy
um I'll tell you what I don't carry that
a lot of people do that I've decided
over the last couple months or these
like will tell you right after this
commercial break I'm actually dying no
it's these punch cards man like ah you
know how we'll go to the good food store
and like we'll get a smoothie or we'll
get a juice and like good food stores uh
the local equivalent of Whole Foods here
in Missoula Montana
yeah and like you go to the counter and
they said you have your punch card and I
was always like oh yeah I got it and
then the other day I found literally
found three punch cards um when you
added them all together was like
one-and-a-half punch cards stamped and I
have no idea where along the lines I had
misplaced those punch cards or maybe
they were Mariah's or something but I
started getting anxiety over like oh man
I wasted my punches like yes it stresses
me out and yeah I was there the other
day and I ordered I ordered a juice and
the the woman's like do you have your
punch card on you and I just said no she
goes do you wanna start a new one no no
she's like are you sure I'm like yeah
they really stressed me out and it's
really not worth the extra punch how
much do you save right and we juice
they're five bucks and I'm not saying
the five dollars isn't a lot I'm just
saying that for me when I look at my
resources when I look at my time when I
look at my attention I would rather pay
the five dollars then keep track of
those punch cards when you yeah when you
advertise a juice and it's 20 punches
for one juice we're talking something
like a quarter each time and really what
you're talking about is my time and
attention that I focus on now other
people I know people who actually get a
ton of value for my clipping coupons and
just excitement is your way from that
sitting down and it becomes this
experience for them and so that's great
we're not saying not to carry that but
the question is is a
worth carrying the worth carrying yeah
you know I first heard this voicemail
I thought Matt said everyday carrot like
carrot and stick like is there something
that came out of ated every day
that's a elderly different question but
it gives many ideas about like what's
your everyday carrot in our our first
book book called minimalism live a
meaningful life we wrote about the five
values I would say those are my everyday
carrots the things that keep me
motivated when when I get off track or
out of focus I always have to go back
and say okay it does this serve any of
my values those five eyes are health
relationships passion growth
contribution and I find the things I get
the most value from in life tend to
fulfill more than one of those values so
those are my everyday carrots in terms
of what do I carry on me every day I
always have chapstick on me
chassis is my everyday in a crowbar and
body bags and bleach no I carry
chapstick all the time because I'm
terrified of chap licks lips especially
living out out west yeah it's pretty dry
out here but but generally no I mean as
long as I have my wallet on me I don't
even need my phone I generally my phone
in the car a lot I don't have to have
something on me all the time
whoo I just thought of something I
carried what's that that other people
might get value from I know you don't
carry one of these but I do it's a like
a multi functioning tool that goes on my
keychain it actually looks like a key
when it folds together there's a few
different variations of this there's one
our friend Drew Capernaum he actually
invented one called the everyman it's
basically a multifunctional tool that I
will use to cut open a box like we get a
box of books it's really nice to have
that key on me I can open up and use it
in fact I know that when you and I are
together you asked me for that tool
quite about quite a bit yeah I mean
that's the nice thing about being a
minimalist you just ask your friends for
stuff right exactly or it has like a
little screwdriver on it that I've
totally used for little odds and ends
things but it's just a nice little tool
that I carry with me that goes on my
keychain it doesn't fill up my pocket
any more than the key would and I use it
a lot I use it if it's not every day
it's every other day but I use it quite
a bit
move on to our next voicemail this one
is from Casey something I'm seeing all
over YouTube right now is the Khan Mari
method of decluttering she claims is the
Japanese art of decluttering and I'm
just curious what you think of it and
how you feel it's any different than
what you are teaching Josh what do you
think about the konmari method I've seen
a lot about it we've had a lot of people
who come out to our events or people
have mentioned it a ton on social media
and so I think a lot of people get value
from it I think that it deals a lot more
with the stuff side of things it's it's
a how-to method and I was listening to
the the slate podcast the the culture
gap fest which I've mentioned and
recommended in the past
Julia Turner and a few other people over
there and it's a great podcast but they
had an episode called the spark boy
edition and and they they sort of talked
about the the I think in their words
draconian mists of the connemara method
and and how it is great in terms of how
to but but I think the way that it
differs from what Ryan and I do is we'll
approach a lot of the how to stuff and
give some practical tips for minimalism
for sure but but a lot of what we do is
more of the what to and especially the
why to and the reason that's so
important is I think if we don't
understand the purpose the why to behind
minimalism then we can declutter our
calls that's all we want but if we don't
know why we're doing it then that calls
that we just decluttered will be
brimming with new purchases in the
not-too-distant future and so but by
addressing the why I think we're able to
get enough leverage to determine why
we're doing and then what we should do
what we should be focused on and then we
can move over to the how-to stuff I mean
let's face it how to declutter your
closet it's fairly simple there are some
tips and tactics that may help you a
little bit but we all know how to
declutter our homes
and I think we need to be careful and
Kumari certainly doesn't advocate just
organizing stuff but a lot of we spoke
at a conference last year the National
Association for professional organizers
we gave a keynote address there and
jokingly I was going to give a 13 word
speech first year the best way to
organize your stuff is to get rid of
most of it and you know I think the the
true home organizers the people who do
this for a living they realize that
organizing is is a misnomer because it's
not about just putting all your stuff in
ordinal bins and having a system that
it's not systematizing your clutter it's
actually about getting the stuff out of
the way that doesn't bring you joy
anymore that doesn't serve a purpose in
your life and so if the connemara method
helps you out I think that's great but I
would ask you to get leverage figure out
why you're doing what you want to do and
then also and far more important where
are you going once you get rid of the
stuff you could rent a dumpster get rid
of all of it and be miserable the point
is what are you going to focus on once
you've got that out of the way yeah
absolutely
and whether you're using an approach
like the packing party or the connemara
method or the 30-day minimalism game
whatever it is I think the key is is
that you start with something and you
start with a plan and you follow through
with that plan so you know personally
what do I think about the connemara
method it's there and there are some
very good steps and she asks a lot of
good questions like what do you want
your life to look like and I think it's
a great place to start I think that's
something we are you know huge advocates
too it's like what are your values and
beliefs what do you want to revolve your
life around so certainly it is an
approach that has worked for a lot of
people and if it like Josh said if it
works for you great try it out feel free
to send us a comment let us know how
that method worked out for you let's
listen to the next voicemail from Sarah
do you have any suggestions to help stop
compulsive buying habits or how you
determine before you buy something
whether an item will actually add value
you to your life how to stop compulsive
buying habits yeah I think there are a
couple questions that we ask one I got
from Ryan and one question I asked
myself the first question that to ask is
can I afford this and that doesn't just
mean financially I think it's a good
good question to start with can I afford
this financially meaning am I not going
to go into debt and is there a better
way for me to spin these resources but
other resources other than money are
just as important time attention space
in our home space in our minds but by
consuming more stuff we're constantly
activating that that portion of our mind
that that is consumed with consumption
yeah it's it's interesting I was reading
this article at the Seattle Times
website Marcia richens she's a journal
of consumer research she talks about how
people who are materialistic who buy
more than other consumers are willing to
go into debt to buy things they can't
afford because they believe their lives
will be transformed by the purchases so
what she's saying is like these people
who go into debt buying compulsively are
doing so thinking that their lives are
going to be transformed and I think
that's that's somewhere Sarah can start
with is each purchase that she's looking
at buying is it actually going to
transform her life especially this
minimalist lifestyle that she's kind of
forced into because of work she has to
move internationally all the time it
would be a very easy thing like okay is
this souvenir is this going to really
change my life or should I just maybe
appreciate this souvenir and leave it on
the shelf
so I think that question is really
important yeah I mean and the other
question to ask is is this going to add
value to my life and how do you define
adding values what she asked and for me
that's does it serve a purpose or does
it bring me joy and I'm constantly
trying to figure that out and it changes
over time I'm 34 years old now and the
things that serve the purpose of 25 are
different from 10 years later and the
same will be true at 45 and plus we have
to define what what happiness is and in
that case and I think it's an old stoic
definition of happiness as the the lack
of suffering and if I if I look at it
that way are the things going
make you suffer less you may be familiar
with the the the term hedonic adaptation
or the hedonic treadmill and that that
basically the the idea with the hedonic
treadmill is that humans quickly return
to a relatively stable level of
happiness despite any sort of big
positive gains that they've ever had so
you may get really excited in the moment
because you won the lottery or you
purchase this new car or you bought a
diamond ring or whatever you you get
this initial burst of dopamine and joy
from that but is it actually going to
bring you joy in a more long-term sense
it doesn't mean it has to forever but
often our purchases that hi we get it
doesn't last far past the checkout line
and we're going to be measured with that
Ryan's mentioned something earlier about
putting it on a list and there are two
kinds of lists you can work with here
one of the lists that I have like when I
go grocery shopping I never ever buy
anything that isn't on my list so I'm in
that has helped me out so much and I
might go to the store and all I knew I
wanted to put herbal tea on the list but
because I've I've forced myself to be
rigid in that it curbs the the impulse
buy and so I have to put it on the list
for next time I have to make it a little
bit inconvenient for myself and
sometimes that sucks most of the time it
really saves my butt from from
purchasing things that I don't really
need the other thing you can do is put
it on a 30-day waitlist like if there's
something you really want especially if
it's a big purchase so set a threshold
if it's over 20 bucks or something put
it on a list and say I'm not going to
buy this thing for at least 30 days and
at the end of those 30 days once you've
been contemplating it researching it
deciding whether or not you need it then
you can pull the trigger if you've
determined that yes I can't afford it
that's question number one I can afford
it emotionally I can afford it
monetarily I can afford it the time and
attention and space this thing takes up
I can afford to take care of it because
by the way we buy more
things we have to take care of it you
buy a piece of furniture has to be
dusted it has to be taken care of and so
kind of afford all of that and if I
can't afford it the is it really going
to to serve a purpose in my life and is
it going to bring me joy and and
thinking of joy is it going to leave
some alleviate some sort of suffering
yeah life going back to the example of
that snowboard that I wanted to get the
$25 demo so I tried it out I actually
did end up buying that snowboard after a
very deliberate month of research
comparing it to other snowboards and
then eventually saying okay I want to
buy this but I still don't have to buy
it I could still just try it out and
that's what I did and then ended up
really really loving it and really
really finding that it did bring me joy
it totally increase my my snowboarding
game but you know I just wanted to
mention one more that it's wanted to
mention one more thing
March origins the marketing professor at
the University of Missouri she talks
about very similar what you said earlier
about the high not going past the
checkout line but she says although
materialists still experience positive
emotions after making a purchase these
emotions are less intense than before
they actually acquire a product meaning
that the thought of the purchase gets
the consumer more high than the actual
purchase so that is something to
definitely take into consideration I
think that right there is just
ammunition to not go off the list right
it's like when you're de store you get
that initial impulse you ignore that
because you know that chances are after
you buy it you're not going to
appreciate it as much as you thought you
would yeah then the last thing that
maybe asked is does this have a place in
my life or is this appropriate for my
life or is maybe the better question is
this the most appropriate use of my
money and because for me I could I
afford to purchase a snowboard right now
yeah probably but it wouldn't be an
appropriate use of my money I hate
snowboarding and and so that there would
it would be silly for me to go purchase
snowboard now you know what in my
corporate days of yesteryear because I
had the money
and all my friend Ryan snowboards
should own a snowboard too and that
that's sort of keeping up with the
Joneses mentality and yeah I might use
that someday well yeah just because you
can't afford it doesn't mean that it's
the most appropriate use of of your
money and so think about that before you
make the purchase is there a better way
for me to spend my money and then the
last thing that you mentioned Ryan about
the material list are we in our
documentary which comes out in theaters
May 24 2016 or is it minimalism film.com
you know what we're super excited about
that but there is a whole segment in in
that documentary about stuff and the
accumulation of stuff and and what is
doing not not just to the sort of
degradation of our planet but what is
doing to us as individuals and us as a
society as a whole and we have a woman
in there named Julia Shore and and she
talks about how we are to materialist in
the traditional sense of purchasing all
of these things but in a different sense
maybe we're not materialist enough I
mean we don't care about the stuff
enough that we bring into our lives
because we are treating everything as if
it's disposable the staff from earlier
99% of the things we purchase we throw
out within sit within six months well
that means we don't actually care about
the things we bring into our life and a
lot goes into the production of these
things and so we need to be careful
about what we're bringing into our life
we've developed this culture of fast
consumption and fast fashion whereas
there are 52 clothing cycles every year
we used to have two to four seasons of
you know what's in trend so to speak and
now we have fifty two seasons of What's
in trend that it changes weekly and so
we need to be careful just because
something is unfashionable anymore it
doesn't mean that it that we need to go
and consume the the next new thing and
so asking whether or not something is
appropriate allows us to be materialist
in the best sense of the word care about
the stuff we we bring into
Our Lives let's move on to our next
voicemail this one comes from Angela do
you follow the mentality of owning a
certain number of kitchen items or
clothing or any of that I know there's
some different groups that promote that
type of minimalism and also wondering if
ever on your essays on your vlog if you
have or would post pictures of your home
I think it's always interesting to see
what a minimalist home does look like
how many things do you own Ryan you know
it's funny when you first introduced me
to the idea of minimalism
I remember you sent me that video of
Colin right where he was kind of going
through and talking about his 51 things
right it was such a turn-off for me yeah
I'm like I really admire this this
gentleman and the life that he lives I
wanted to live his life like at the time
like I just wanted to pick up and go
right but the idea of having 51 things
was like that's really silly to to limit
it to a number now that's not what Colin
was doing he wasn't limiting it to a
number he was just sharing with the
world like hey these are the things I
travel with because this is what fits my
lifestyle and it made perfect sense so I
don't count my stuff to me that is
missing the whole point for me as to why
I decided to go down this road of
simplicity in living a deliberate life
yeah I'd like to joke that I have a list
of all of my possessions but I threw
away the list because I didn't wanted to
count as one possession when I was first
introduced to minimums my I felt the
same way I saw this sort of contest this
quick contest to the bottom where I'm
the most minimalist I'm more minimalist
than your minimalist I only own twenty
things my less is less than your less
more or less than your lunch uh yeah and
and so what was actually but but I agree
with you too like it was sort of
admirable in a way when I looked at
someone like Colin he owned 51 things
but that's because his passion is to
travel to a new country every four month
right he can't necessarily carry a
loveseat with him right when I lives in
Argentina for four months and then bring
it back right I like having to catch
table personally yeah and I wouldn't do
very well
traveling perpetually trying to get the
the kitchen table onto the airplane and
stick it in like the the overhead bin
but for Colin those 51 things are what's
appropriate for his life for those of
you don't know we're talking about a
friend of ours business partner for our
publishing company as well
his name's Colin right you can find his
blog at exile lifestyle com if you're
interested in and seeing his whole
journey but yeah he took a photo with
like I think the 51 things that he owned
at the time and he's in our documentary
as well because that is a different
approach toward minimalism it's
certainly not my approach in fact when I
first found minimalism I found all these
different recipes there were people like
him or Dave Bruno who wrote a book
called the hundred thing challenge who
you know he has a whole family but he
just lived with a hundred things for
over the course of one year and even
Dave would tell you that the number
itself 100 items was arbitrary and when
we first started our our website at the
minimalists com
I wrote an essay very early on so I
think is late 2010 actually it was it
was called the 288 things I own it was
sort of making fun of myself but also
making fun of the the contest of of
competing to be the most less I love
when that comes up in interviews and
like they don't get the satire right
tell us about the 288 things you won't
why is that number important to you you
didn't read the essay did you well
you're exactly and so even an essay
talks about it being this sort of
parodic exaggeration because I found
that when people were counting their
stuff sometimes they'd group things
together it really I don't 72 things but
all of my underwear counts is one thing
and so in this essay I grouped all my
books together that was one thing all of
my underwear was one thing my t-shirts
were one thing and the joke was that
okay so the average American household
has more than 300 thousand items in it
if you get rid of 90 percent of your
stuff which I did does that mean I own
thirty thousand items you probably I
have no idea how many items I own now
jokingly I took an inventory of my stuff
but here's a weird weird side of that is
by taking that even the joking inventory
of my stuff and going through
counting my 288 items and grouping a
bunch of stuff it did help me start to
question the things I still had in my
life and so I would suggest it even as a
joke to go through and take a look at
yourself take a sort of physical
inventory of your things and you might
find that you don't need as much of the
stuff that you had even as you're paring
down going through your whole minimalist
journey and we've had a lot of people
who they'll do Ryan's packing party or a
version of it they'll just do a packing
party in one room or they'll do a
packing party in their closet or maybe
they're playing on our 30-day minimalism
game which you can find out more about
it the minimalists comm slash game but
but whatever you're doing it's really
about starting to question the stuff
that is in your life and so if you want
to live with a number because that makes
it easier for you great I'll tell you
this I own somewhere between 288 and
30,000 items maybe I have I have no idea
I don't know much you come to my house
right now you walk in and you'd say wow
this place is really tidy and it's not
because I go around and I'm cleaning up
and tidying up all the time no I don't
have a lot of stuff to get in the way
and the final question there was about
apartment tours yes you can actually
find an old apartment tour of my
apartment when I lived in Dayton Ohio
which is where Ryan and I are from at
the minimalists comm slash apartment you
can also follow us on Instagram we did a
bunch of stuff in our homes recently
we're at the minimalists on Instagram
I'm going to do an apartment tour I
think this spring coming up if you want
to follow me on Instagram as well or you
can just go to at the minimalists
there's another article somewhere with
when we were living together in
Phillipsburg oh yeah the cabin tour yeah
that's a great that's a great one right
so when we first moved out to Montana we
moved to a cabin in the middle of
nowhere
and so you can you can actually take a
we were out there for four months
writing a book of ours called everything
that remains and so we where we were out
there we lived in a cabin on the side of
the mountain
you can do a photo tour of that cabin at
the minimalists comm slash cabin and to
everyone who left us a voicemail today
katelyn and
and Casey and Sarah and Angela we have
an entire chapter about stuff that's
actually called stuff it's the the
second chapter in our book essential and
I think it's the longest chapter in that
book so I'm going to send each of you a
copy of that book we really hope that
you enjoy it for sure and you know we'd
love to hear what you all the audience
has to say about stuff so if you have a
comment about stuff including minimalism
tips on how to simplify your stuff or or
how to bring stuff into your life in a
intentional way then you can give us a
call four oh six two one nine seven
eight three nine will air some of our
favorite comments and tips on the next
episode and if your voicemail is
selected we'll send you a allograft copy
of one of our books probably a copy of
essential or maybe minimalism love a
meaningful life or everything that
remains it's my personal favorite
you know one thing I just want to add
that I think will help all of these
questions through voice mail is just try
stuff out just do some experiments see
what life is like if you get rid of one
of those a pair of scissors that you
keep for scrapbooking what happens when
you don't have it for a month or what
happens when you stop buying everything
except consumable goods for a week just
try different things out like that I'd
love to hear our listeners comments when
it comes to their experiments and what
they've tried on what has worked there
or what hasn't worked for that matter
absolutely and grab a grab a
accountability partner too when you're
playing that minimalism game it will
help keep you accountable but it'll also
help you have some great stories you can
share with our audience via voicemail
alright so speaking of comments here are
some voicemail comments from our last
episode Kay minimalist this is Andy
calling from Evanston Illinois I'm
calling to respond to your education
episode I think that it is our duty to
go above and beyond and become as
educated as we can to contribute to the
world as much as we possibly can to help
those who don't have the same
opportunities hi my name is Cassandra
halfrek I have a very overzealous
grandmother who buys my son everything
under the Sun so what I do is I not
afraid to give it away or even just to
return it and if you can get back cash
for that why not put it into a college
fund something that you can start for
them in their future something that is
useful for them if you can't get cash
back for it what I'll do is get a gift
card or whatever you need for it and
then buy something that they will need
whether it be like diapers or wife
something that they can find useful even
for yourself if you can't you know if
whatever you don't need for that your
child can you get something useful for
yourself like detergent or dish soap so
that's what I try and do this is
Christine and I'm calling from Arlington
Nebraska I listened to your podcast on
education and I was really interested in
it because I'm been in education for 23
years 18 as a language arts high school
language arts instructor in the last
five years is a professional school
counselor so I was really interested in
what you had to say about the topic and
you know you guys have really hit it you
know dead on we have an education system
that's broken and and I work with a lot
of kids who have some behavior issues
and I'm fully convinced that if they had
more hands-on experiences and they were
getting up and moving around and
learning by doing those behavior issues
would've a pure evaporate and I'm also
convinced that we have you know kids
that are leaving high school and we
expect them at 18 years old to know
exactly what they want to do and they
don't and they need to have the
opportunity to have different
experiences and learn and grow and and
figure out their their way of whether
it's a traditional higher education or
into a trade school or in an
apprenticeship so there's all different
kinds of opportunities and we try to
pigeonhole them into cookie cutters and
kids aren't cookie cutters and if we
want them to contribute to society in a
meaningful way we need to you know
individualize their learning and see how
they grow from there my name is Jessica
I am from Richmond Virginia and I just
wanted to call and thank you in general
for your blog in your books
most recently for the podcast on
education I am currently a law student
and have been really struggling with
deciding what jobs take after school do
I pursue my passions which are in
environmental justice and environmental
policymaking which case considerably
less than going through the big freedom
route and I really your podcasts
intercom at a better time because it
just reminded me that I chose to go to
law school to help other people and make
changes and this is the area that I
found I felt passionate about hi guys
it's Michelle regarding the most recent
podcast and education I would like to
suggest that anybody who is interested
in pursuing higher education feels that
they can't do that because of fear of
going into debt or you know just lack of
resources lack of money lack of time but
there are not-for-profit organizations
or nonprofit organizations out there
that do offer education assistance
programs and if you're fortunate to
attain employment with one of those
organizations then they almost
definitely in most circumstances pay for
your education that you know not only
enables you to advance a career but also
gives you the opportunity to you know to
learn and grow and and follow something
that is that is you know meaningful to
you this is Preston and I am from a lot
of places currently Columbus Ohio prior
to listening to the forth podcast on
education I was taking a graduate level
class because several people in my
company had told me would help me
further my education further my progress
within the company but I wasn't
passionate about it I mean it just it
wasn't interesting to me it's just
something I had to do so I decided to
drop it and I thought to myself why do I
need another degree why can't I just
take classes on things that interests me
I want to know more about the stock
market
take a class on that through becoming a
minimalist I realized I loved my fish
tanks so why not take some marine
biology classes I want to know more
about my own health so why not take some
nutrition
existing classes so yeah everything is
you guys said in podcast number four
verify what I was thinking and I
appreciated that education doesn't have
to be in a form of a degree it can be
ongoing and it could be several
different things community colleges your
own informal education all of those okay
let's move on to our iTunes comment of
the week right all right this iTunes
comment of the week comes from squirrel
1920 we have squirrels listen to this
podcast that is awesome finally a
minimalist podcast that is actually
helpful and is not some sanctimonious
clowns bragging about how big a
minimalist they are you know I like to
think of myself as sanctimonious and as
ryan as the clown right I'm definitely
not a sanctimonious clown though yeah
that's that would be an insult but no
thank you
it goes on to say this podcast is
helpful and insightful with two very
real relatable and funny hosts well Josh
and I do think we are the two funniest
people in the world just ask us we'll
tell you thank you for some real help
and advice to bring a sense of balance
in my life thank you thank you squirrel
really appreciate that
that awesome comment yeah really
definitely if you want so if you really
want some some funny comments from
someone we're gonna send you a copy of
everything that remains so everything
that remains is a book that Ryan and I
worked on for a while it's the thing I'm
most proud of that I've ever worked on
and it's about 200 pages but throughout
those 200 and it's written by me in a
sort of first-person perspective but
throughout those 200 pages there are a
hundred and eight interruptions from
Ryan and some of them are smart-alecky
remarks or him just just pointing out
ridiculousness of things that I'm that
I'm doing and so we'll send you a copy
of that we really appreciate the the
comment there I think it's funny
the the one reporter who was asking you
about everything that remains and
they're like we noticed that you let
Ryan get all of the last words in with
everything I thought that was pretty
funny but yeah check it out it's great
read and for anyone else who wants to
leave a positive honest review it really
helps our our simple living message
reach more ears and we'll keep reading
some of our favorite iTunes comments on
the air you can also leave them on on
stitcher now we're on the the podcast
platform stitcher so you could if you
listen over there you can you can check
it out and feel free to get creative
with your with your comments so we can
air some of our favorites and we'll keep
out sending some books out to some of
our favorites and I'd love to move on to
a quick lightning round of hashtag ask
the minimalist of I've got some
questions here from Instagram and
Twitter we're at the minimalists on both
of those platforms and we say can we say
lightning round and then insert some
like really cheesy lightning noises
let's get ready for lightning round
we're on Facebook - facebook.com slash
the minimalists there we go let's see
our first question is what your take as
far as minimalism in the community such
as charitable work and getting involved
you know I didn't do a whole lot of
charitable work before I became a
minimalist before I started living a
more simple life because I didn't really
have the time to do so maybe I would
give 10 bucks here 20 bucks there to
something but I certainly didn't invest
in Habitat for Humanity or soup kitchens
or other charitable works like I do now
but I do think one of the best parts of
life is being able to give and being
able to to help people out when they're
in need absolutely if you want to feel
truly fulfilled its contributing beyond
yourself in a meaningful way so so find
a way to do that a great website to get
started with that would be give well.org
next question is do you keep a music
collection in iTunes or are you engulfed
by Spotify
well I'm engulfed by iTunes radio yeah I
use it a lot to listen to music now I
don't have to own an album I don't have
to download any that stuff I have the
option to do that
it's ten bucks a month I know a lot of
people who find that ten bucks a month
to listen to whatever they want and it
certainly adds value to my life I don't
buy albums anymore yeah I mean I think
we're shifting from a culture of
ownership to a culture of access and for
the very first time do we now have these
these sort of consumer goods we
traditionally call them whether it's
books or music or whatever we don't have
to own a physical artifact anymore and I
really love that I would just say you
know use whatever you get the most value
from I really enjoy Apple music right
now Spotify is also great there Spotify
is very simple they have really great
playlists I like Apple music because
it's something I'm used to and I've used
iTunes for a while pandora is another
great option but the question is what
what do you enjoy most which interface
do you really like and same goes with
books you know we have a lot of readers
who have a Kobo which is a type of
e-reader I use a Kindle personally
because it syncs with my phone and my
Kindle and my audiobooks as well so they
all sync up together
it's about no longer needing to consume
and hold on to all of these things but
having access to the actual information
so if that's music it's the music itself
though the listening experience and this
is all about having an experience rather
than then hoarding a collection of of
things
our next question and hashtag asks the
minimalists what tips do you have for
quote but I paid good money for that I
just can't give it away oh wow
I was this other article I was reading
on the BBC it talked about how we over
value so many things so many things like
I figured what it gave the example of
beanie baby collections and how they are
worth pennies compared to what people
spent on them years ago and they might
go back up in price one day but the fact
is is that we over value a lot for me it
was these cell phones right we worked at
a cell phone company so we had this
unlimited access to these
cellphones that would retail for 500 600
700 800 dollars which by the way people
don't understand the like that's what
the phones actually cost right so so
even more even more so I would over
perceive the value because I know what
we paid for those phones and so if I've
got a drawer full of four or five cell
phones I would look in there and see two
thousand bucks when in reality wasn't
even close to that yeah there are a few
things there is planned obsolescence
perceived obsolescence there's a new iOS
update that comes out for the iPhone
every month or two or whatever I
challenge you to try to put that on on
an iPhone to you if you you're using the
the software for the iPhone 6 it just
doesn't work anymore
and so that's one of the reasons that a
phone is worth less but then the
perceived obsolescence is all of my
friends have something that's cool when
that that's where it becomes dangerous
definitely we're we're we have we look
at oh my friend has the new iPhone 6s
and I have only the iPhone 6 and that
means I am out of trend I and I am no
longer caught up we were talking to Sam
Harris in our documentary about this but
you know the thing that we really
yearned for we strive to get that new
widget after we get it and we've had it
for a little while it's no longer a
source of satisfaction is actually a
source of discontent because the newest
latest greatest thing comes out and
we're looking over the shoulder of the
thing that we had and we thought would
bring us joy and now it's now it is now
the source of our dissatisfaction
because we want the newest greatest
thing and this question here Troy about
why I paid good money for that that's
really a sunk cost right yeah you may
have paid good money for it but doesn't
mean that it's worth that anymore and so
if you look up some calls in that
economics and it's basically like yeah
we've already wasted that money you're
never going to get it back if you have a
chance to get something back great sell
it to someone else who can get value
from it yeah it's like if you buy a new
car off the lot it loses thousands of
dollars as soon as you drive it off the
car lot you try to sell it the next day
you're going to
lose thousands of dollars its son cost
Barbie asks what tips do you have the
combat hoarding instincts and she says
besides the $20 replacement rule you
know I let's actually talk about that's
probably the best rule if you employ it
judiciously what she's talking about
there's what we call the just-in-case
rule and you can read about that at the
minimalists comm /j IC but basically
it's like this $20 20 minutes if you
need to to replace something in your
life it's going to cost $20 and you're
going to get in less than 20 minutes now
that I mean you have to consume it right
but it means you are allowed to let go
of things because the beauty of the
just-in-case rule is in many of the
things we hold on to just in case we
don't actually need them at all and so
we have to treat just in case as a
non-existent hypothetical I think
definitely so in addition to the 20/20
rule I think that the 9090 rule would
work really well and maybe 1990 maybe
that's not enough for you maybe
someone's like whoa you know I was
pregnant last the last six months and
now I'm not you know there are
circumstances that come up I've heard
that excuse given specifically it's why
I bring it up maybe it's the 12-month
12-month or whatever it is make rules
for yourself you know I would argue to
it before this podcast Josh and I were
going over some stats and just about
consumption and how things were going in
the economy with the environment it was
it was stressing us out how downhill the
environment is going I know for me after
watching the stats I started thinking
like what am I getting right now like I
was literally when we were looking at
those stats I thought to myself how can
I get detergent in a in a reusable
container is that possible like I'm sure
it is but that's where my mind started
going and I would encourage whoever
asked that question I would encourage
you to look at what that hoarding is
doing to the environment and at least
help that will help shift your
perspective a little bit yeah I think
about it this way we all need some stuff
sure consumption isn't the ultimate
problem but we have gotten to a position
where we consume on impulse we consume
compulsively we consume because we think
that's the American dream we think
that's what's right for the economy and
the truth is that we can choose not to
do it yeah it's like Patrick Ron said in
our documentaries like sometimes you
just got to turn it off
absolutely and that that goes with our
urge to to consume as well I've got a
few more questions here one one from
Scott he says I love movies but my
collection is becoming clutter
what would a minimalist do about a
collection of movies oh I bet he's got a
big collection of VHS tapes is that what
it is tapes or does it say Disney he
doesn't say but it's funny because
sometimes we'll do events and tour
toward the beginning I'll just say hey
how many of you have VHS is at home and
but yeah 30 or 40 percent of the raise
their hand yeah and that's okay
now how many of you leave your hand up
if you have a VCR and only about half
the hands stay up and it's like wait a
minute you have a bunch of VHS but you
don't have a VCR yeah and and okay I
realized that you might have some home
movies or whatever and that's all I'm
talking about I'm talking about that the
duplicate copy you have of Air Bud v on
VHS you know it's not it's not actually
bringing any joy to your life here's the
cool thing about what we were just
talking about earlier we are in a
culture of access if you have Netflix or
Apple TV or whatever you now have access
to virtually unlimited movies you no
longer have to have that collection of
things and oh by the way if you've
already watched the movie one time
what's the likelihood that you're going
to watch it again it's very very small
and if you want to keep watching the
same movie over and over again is that
the best use of your time only you could
decide for me it's certainly not the
best use of my time
I would encourage Scott to just pick
like that the 10 of your videos DVDs
whatever you have that you haven't
watched in the last four or five years
and just go donate those and see how it
feels you're going to realize that it
doesn't feel that bad the question
clearly
said that he is feeling pain you know
this this this collection this thing
that brought him joy is saying that did
serve a purpose is now creating this
this pain point and I would say right
there is like the red flag for you to
start to get rid of your movie
collection or you know for the other
listeners who have a library that's now
stressing them out moving those books
around and taking care of those like
that's a sign you should start getting
rid of that stuff a couple more here one
from Alonso says do you still buy
hardcopy books yeah I still buy hardcopy
books actually gave me a book not too
long ago to read which was a really nice
gift and I'm really enjoying the book um
but yeah I have about 15 hardcopy books
most of them are reference though the
ones that aren't reference I will donate
I will get rid of I will pass it on I
will minimize it when I'm done reading
it the majority of the books I have now
are on my Kindle on my on my laptop or
on my phone I just used the Kindle app
and keep most of my books there yeah I
agree I think it's great if you want to
buy physical books too to give out as
gifts I always encourage people to
minimize the book after they're done you
know find someone else who can get value
from it because it doesn't get a lot of
value just sitting on the shelf the
value is in the words the value is not
in maintaining or retaining a physical
artifact our last question is from
Zachary York he says do you still give
out free hugs at your meetups of course
not only are they free but they are
transferable so you can hand them out to
thousands of other people as well I was
a cool thing about back in 2014 we did a
100 City Tour 119 events eight countries
and this we had something like 75,000
people RSVP for that so he gave out tens
of thousands of hugs and you get this
sort of kinesthetic learning this
experience that you don't get otherwise
and I've become a lot better at hugging
too I've learned so so the hugs now if
you got one a few years ago I would say
that I'm more of an expert hugger than I
once was we love to go out there
I've learned there a couple kinds of
hugs too you've got the the get to slow
dance hug yeah that's that's the one
right they embrace you hold it for an
extra two or three onion second sway a
little bit in at our events we get kind
of sweaty as you sweat on the person
know and in the sort of the broad tap
and I found I used to do that a lot more
and that was that was just just because
you get uncomfortable with physical
contact I found and I'm no longer
uncomfortable with physical contact so
if you if you see me you'll you'll get a
slightly more of a slow dance hug than
you might be expecting
ladies and gentlemen Joshua fields no
burn expert hugger yeah and so we are
actually hitting the road in in May 14
different cities you can join us all of
our our tour dates there but you can
come get a hug
you can find tour dates at the
minimalists comm slash tour let's move
on to our added value portion of the
show where we each recommend something
that has added value to our lives either
recently or in the past I'll go ahead
and start with there's a video it's
about 20 minute video called the story
of stuff which seems apropos here it was
a woman created in 2007 and here are
here's the synopsis of the video I
encourage you to check it out we'll also
put a link to the video in the show
notes from its extraction through sale
use and disposal all the stuff in our
lives affects communities at home and
abroad yet most of this is hidden from
view the story of stuff is a 20 minute
fast-paced fact filled look at the
underside of our production and
consumption patterns and so if you get a
chance check out the story of stuff
it'll give you the in-between in the
hidden side of things not just the
manufacturing and consumption side of
things but everything that goes into
what makes our stuff and if you're
looking for a comical take on stuff I
would take a look at George Carlin's
video about stuff you can go to the
minimalists com
/ stuck classic totally classic that
one's hilarious today I would like to
recommend a donation box to place in
your home you can find your donation box
at the minimalists com4 i'm just kidding
just grab an old just grab an old
cardboard box or crate this is something
that Mariah and I do and what's really
cool is like for example we got a
donation box right now that's full of
stuff we need to take it out but that
has taken us the last I'd say two months
to fill so what's awesome is that I
totally commit to donating something and
maybe I'll twitch a little bit be like
huh maybe I shouldn't donate that maybe
I'll need it you know I'll still have
that 30 to 60 days to to see if I
actually need it or not yeah and what's
cool too is it totally is something that
Mariah and I are on the same page with
something that you know an activity that
brings us a little bit closer together
and I think with a family like donation
box is perfect especially to show you
know young children like hey this is
stuff we don't need anymore we're going
to put it in this box and we're gonna go
bring it to the store so someone else
who does need it can find use in it so
yeah get into mine every every month so
I first of each month
I'll go to the take it take it to the
donation place wherever you want to
donate I tend to go to Goodwill but we
have a couple really great places here
in Missoula so you can go to donation
town org and you can find some really
great places to donate your stuff as
well yes finally let's move on to our
last segment a little something we call
right here right now this is the stuff
we're excited about things that are
going on in the lives of the minimalists
as I mentioned already we are going on
the road or we're getting into our tour
bus which is Ryan's Toyota Corolla and
and we're hitting the road for a month
May 1st to June 1st 14 different cities
and we're bringing our documentary on
the road we're also bringing this
podcast on the road so we're going to do
some recordings of hashtag ask the
minimalists in in person some live
events we're really excited to share
this documentary with you if you haven't
seen the new trailer you should
definitely check it out you can go to
our youtube page at youtube.com slash
the minimalists or our facebook page
and and we post a new trailer and so
much great feedback you're going to get
just a little hint a taste of what is in
store this documentary is phenomenal our
director Matt Dee Avella is a genius and
we have put together this week's for the
last you know two plus years of our
lives working on this interviewing
minimalist entrepreneurs minimalist
designers and architects and families
and economists and neuroscientists and
everything in between and we're
presenting a bunch of different recipes
for how to live a more meaningful life
so you can find the the trailer actually
you find all of this stuff art or the
trailer and you can also figure out how
to bring this documentary to your city
we already have over a hundred
screenings that are are scheduled all
over the United States and you can if
there isn't a screening near you you can
actually bring this documentary to your
community it's really really simple all
the details are at minimalism film.com
now if you're not in the United States
don't worry we have a theatrical release
planned for Canada and also one plan for
Australia details are still coming on
that and then we're also working on
overseas distribution as well as a
worldwide release of the film so find
out about when we're going to be in your
city and you can see the trailer you can
see a bunch of other excerpts from the
film all at minimalism film.com and
every Tuesday we're doing Tuesdays with
the minimalists as you probably heard in
our last podcast episode so this Tuesday
this next too is that you can join us on
Twitter or periscope we're answering
your questions live and finally I have a
writing class coming up so I do a
semester long writing class over at how
to write better org and I know that is
time prohibitive or cost prohibitive for
some people so I'm doing it a one day
class on February 7th the workshop you
can find all the details for that at how
to write better org and finally if you
are looking to hang out with like-minded
people if you find yourself not
surrounded by supporting folks who want
to
support your simple lifestyle you can
always go to minimalist dot or we have
100 free local meetup groups that meet
at least once a month
some of them meet multiple times a month
but check your local group out get some
support get some help if you don't find
that we have a local group in your city
that's ok we have an online city that
has a ton of community involvement a ton
of support on there thousands of people
yeah thousands of people on it we
launched that in December and it has
grown so much and I'm really really
happy to see people getting value out of
that online city so don't fret go to
online city you can find some support
there alright y'all well we hope you
found value in this episode and if you
leave here with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time every little thing you think that's
mean every little thing you think
magining every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it
every little thing that you got ahead
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach forward and you got a brain
oh I bet that you'll be fine without me
so chair your tea